this war has never really been about
territory for either side in the case of
Vladimir Putin territory is not really
what he's primarily focused on his
primary goal is to control Ukraine his
original goal of course was maximalist
to install a puet regime in Kiev but at
a minimum he wants to make sure that
Ukraine is torn away from the Western
Alliance beat NATO beat EU and general
affiliation with the west and on the
Ukrainian side even though they
obviously want to get back their
territory and even more importantly get
back their people that is also not the
primary objective the primary objective
is to make sure that this country is
secure and safe for Generations that
Russia will not do again to it what it
has done since 2014 and I think they
would actually take a deal that gives up
at least some of the territory if they
could ensure that they could get those
security guarantees be it primarily
their interests in NATO of course Russia
would never allow that deal to happen so
I just don't see what kind of deal is
possible